I love that you mentioned the fact that
you thought long term about insurance
because it's one of the most timeless
Industries ever it you know regardless
of recession economic time it's not like
real estate that's up and down it's like
you really thought long term I want to
ask because I did see the clip where you
mentioned that you had a 20-year time
Horizon and in this year you know in
this day and age and social media
everyone's trying to make a million
bucks this year two or three million
bucks over the next two or three years
what was the impetus for you to actually
think long term where did that come from
because it's such a obviously you know
we just came literally today from
interviewing uh Bobby and Sophia Castro
they exited their company was at a
billion dollar valuation and they were
saying the same thing that ever every
time he tried a different business
opportunity he was always thinking short
term one year two years the second he
zoomed out and said you know it I'm
gonna
get rich slow so to speak and zoomed out
um that's when things really started to
work even when I interviewed for example
John Paul De jorya founder of uh Patron
tequila and Paul Mitchell shampoo
conditioner he articulated to one of the
most profound points ever he said that
multi-billionaires you know because he
started not one but two multi-billion
dollar companies he said you know they
think in terms of two or three decades
or more uh billionaires think in terms
of you know a decade maybe two people
make a couple hundred million bucks
think in terms of a decade people make
tens of millions of dollars think maybe
you know five to ten years people will
make a couple million bucks think in
terms of two or three years all the way
you know down
to where the lowest paid people in the
world think about their wage per hour
right like minimum wage so the time
Horizon with which they evaluate time
but I'm curious for you where did that
come from where did the where did the
vision of I wrote both of them have a
very good point uh I read a book called
Toyota way
and Toyota we talked about you know how
Toyota went from looking at the assembly
line how it was taken a minute and you
know 48 seconds to solve a problem and
they would bring it down to a minute and
28 seconds to a minute and 11 So
eventually it was like 59 seconds where
problems were being addressed the moment
it's coming up in the assembly line and
you ring the bell and somebody shows up
and a boom fix 59 seconds address next
boom so you sit there and you think
about how these guys think right Toyota
20-year business plan in Toyota
is a short-term business plan do you
know the oldest company in the world the
oldest company in the world where it's
based out of
it's out of Japan it's 1500 years old do
you know how many companies in Japan
are over a hundred years old do you know
the number 50
000.
companies in Japan are over a hundred
years old how are you able to have 50
000 companies over a hundred years old
what is the mindset behind that well one
of the things about building a company
in Japan
the idea is if you're my son I'm
building it because I want to keep close
I want I want to keep the family close
to each other so I'm developing the next
layer you're developing the next layer
he's developed because now family is
going to be fine because the business is
going to be taken care of our last name
right so then the business stays for 300
years 400 years 500 years 180 years so
meaning I've done my part now it's your
part I got the business from my dad now
I'm going to set you up to be the CEO
one day now you're going to do this your
brother is going to do this your
sister's on yeah pass the Baton right so
when you sit there and you I remember
one time I'm competing with this one
girl
it was a her and another guy and at one
event she gets up and she's speaking and
she calls me up and then I go up and I
speak I said let me tell you something I
said you have me maybe in this area in
this other area in this area
there's one area in this business you
don't have me and you will never be able
to compete with me because you don't
have this other area I said it's not
even fair matter of fact to not have you
go through mental issues in the future I
would highly recommend you not competing
with me because it's going to disappoint
you and you're going to live the rest of
your life saying how you couldn't beat
me because there's this one thing that
you don't have that I know I have nah
that sounds a little bit arrogant it may
sound a little bit cocky but I was
convinced this was my age and you know
what the edge was here's what my Edge is
in in success there's four things
outwork which a lot of people do
but for periods of time I would improve
which a lot of people do but for periods
of time
out strategize which a lot of people
could do for periods of time you know
what the last one is outlast most people
cannot last most people are going to get
a million bucks they're happy most
people are going to get a 10 million
bucks they're going to be happy when I
first walked in here like hey how did it
feel with your exit and I said it was
expected it's not like it was a it's a
great feeling I told you the story of my
wife and what happened but I knew this
was coming and I know the next three
four five events that I'm solving for is
coming right and
um
the the challenge is going to be when
that success comes your way and people
say oh I'm never going to stop okay
we'll find out oh Pat I'm Gonna Be Your
Biggest earner cool we'll find out what
you make a quarter million a year
which make a million bucks here wait you
got a million bucks in the back let's
see what time you still wake up in the
morning
let's see if you got 10 million bucks in
the bank let's see what you're
eventually going to do then it happens
to you
and then you're like damn
she was right he was right I got a
million in the bank I don't have the
urgency I had before Bingo that was your
vision a million bucks right
yeah Dana White you know they know got
350 million dollars in 2016 when the
deal was done he said
yeah he's going back to work the same
exact you know what he was doing and
look what he's done with uh you know UFC
to where it's at during covet while
everybody else he became the number one
commissioner everybody's targeting that
of course he had a terrible incident
this last two weeks ago whatever he that
he's already called himself Apple what
he's done but you look at him as a
commissioner you look at him as a guy
that's running an entire sport during
covet he's the MVP two-year MVP back to
back what happened with him he got the
money guess what the marketplace is
realizing that guy's a big thinker 350
million dollars didn't stop him how many
people stop at a point A lot of people
do a lot of people do did that ever
happen to you uh yeah of course one
million percent of course it happened to
me in 2007 when a new guy came and beat
me
and I had to at this one event uh the
speaker said you know this year we're
going to give the MVP in a completely
different way we're going to give the
MVP we're going to have the runner-up
give it to the winner
so they bring me and him up
and they send the MEP goes to they say
him and I have oil yeah but I have
to give the award to him
so I'm like okay
I gave it to him
I handed it to him and I said to him
whisper to him I said listen I got to
give it to you you outwork me this year
I wasn't peridoting enough this year
I wasn't fully focused for the last 12
months but I'm going to tell you this he
says what's that never for the rest of
your life will this ever happen again
it's game over
that that level of paranoia
was re-reminded in that moment one of
the most important books I read by Andy
Grove it said only the paranoid survived
we lose paranoia we run our businesses
as if it's always going to keep growing
you're always going to be successful and
you you don't think that it could go
bankrupt tomorrow you lose the paranoid
you become too caucus like the guy
that's a boxer constantly winning
winning winning winning winning winning
winning winning any boxes like this and
it gets knocked out you lost your
paranoia happens to all of us but
hopefully you hope that happens to you
early on in your career that you can
always go back to it and say hey I know
you just got a big check remember you
could get knocked out hey yeah I know
you're getting a lot of eyeballs
remember hey I know you're doing this
are you still reading are you still
feeding your mind are you still
researching are you still preparing the
questions like you did before are you
still strata are you still recruiting
are you still paying heavy salaries to
recruit the right Talent are you
becoming cheap what are you doing right
now are you that that reminder can
always go back into that so not going to
sit here and tell you I haven't fallen
for that but when I stop
it will be because
I'm done yeah I'm there's only one
person that can stop me with uh what I'm
doing next and it's not going to be me
[Music]